The Joe Rogan Experience that's sick
that's my favorite follow that's stoic
Instagram oh stoic is great yeah Ryan
holiday is great too oh yeah Ryan
holiday yeah he looks like the guy that
killed four college students in Idaho
that's who I thought it was I was like
oh the stomach is a mass murderer he's
out he's out he's writing books about
just being cool about everything but did
you hear that by the way I know they're
thinking about bringing back the firing
squad if he gets convicted oh my god
well they think he might have killed
people in Washington state too is that
where it was it was somewhere else there
was a another place where he lived where
similar similar crime took place and
they think he was studying
um uh crime in in college in order to
get better at it right it's really Eve
it's an evil scary story if if all this
they're accusing him his act of uh is
accurate it's horrific right that guy
was out there right dude you want to
hear a wild story so my mom had a friend
let's see if we could find out if that's
true though yeah which part the part
where
um they think that he might have
committed a similar crime excuse me
somewhere else here we go see this is
what's happening now on an intermittent
fasting stomach I'm going to start
getting crazy it's gonna uh it might get
bad and you want to take another sniff
why the hell not all right here we go
ready
oh that was deep oh Joey we went in I
went
get in there Chrissy
Jamie no no Jamie said no I didn't I
didn't even get his full name out before
Noah was coming out of it Jamie that one
burned that one fogged up my glasses
that one burned baby I get it dude I
want to lift right now seriously
deadlifts I I seriously like yeah like I
want to [__] I want to yeah put the
lid on it I wanna I wanna like start
doing Jiu Jitsu with you I don't even
know how to do it there's nothing like
the a freshie when you open them up
fresh that is refreshing yeah when you
when you let them sit for a while they
lose a lot of their potency like we had
one that was here for a few months and
it had lost a lot of kick but damn when
you open them fresh see anything about
other crimes I'm trying I'm looking
still
um I believe it was where he was
originally going to school he had said
he was Washington State yeah but just
did you Google may have possibly
committed similar crime in Washington
state Washington okay just Google may
have possibly committed wanted for
possibly committing similar crime a lot
of serial killers come from this part of
the country he could be major link to
other murders this is it and this is in
Newsweek okay
no it says um new evidence recovered may
be a major link to the Idaho murders
he's been accused of fatally stabbing
the University of Idaho students the
search warrant which is reported by the
New York Times discussed several items
which is taken from his residence
where is the thing about the other cases
oh here it is attending another place
and December 30th he was arrested as
parents residents in Pennsylvania
um extradited to Idaho is currently
charged coburger was attending
Washington State University at the time
of the murders yeah he looks like the
guy from the stomach but there was he
does looks a lot like them but Ryan
holidays quite a bit more handsome Ryan
Hall is older like media brother Ryan
holiday Hottie with a body
but uh it says Pennsylvania is sifting
through cold cases for links to him oh
it was Pennsylvania interesting
yeah that's who yeah they pulled him
over and it was in his parents house and
because remember the media was saying we
don't know we don't have any leads but
the FBI was following him across the
country yeah they can't just leak yeah
you can't do formation they're in the
middle of an investigation of a [__]
psycho but it is wild like with these
these you know he's famous now for these
murders but as you said could be stuffed
before my mom had a friend right grew up
in um Utah
seven maybe she's 18 19 years old on
whatever year of 70s 80s whatever
goes on a date with a guy right normal
day just met him I think at the
supermarket goes on a date with this guy
and she's
um at the table with him and she feels
very like a ominous feeling looking at
this man she's like I'm looking at him
and I can see like there's nothing
behind his eyes like there's just
something that I don't like about this
guy
so to the point where she has never done
this you know I never she was only 18
but since this has never done this she
went to a pay phone at the restaurant
called her brother and was like can you
please come pick me up like immediately
and stayed in the bathroom and told her
brother was outside and went in the car
and left
and she was like I'm just creeped out by
this guy I can't explain it I'm creeped
out all this energy I'm creeped out
creeped out now he had this man had
picked her up from her house so the
brother had a paper route he's leaving
the next morning at 5am see some
ruffling in the bushes okay crazy right
like whatever sees a guy running out of
the bushes ex says holy [__] whatever
runs back in the house tells his mom and
dad sister wakes up says he was wearing
like a beige jacket she's like that's
the guy was on a date with like that he
was like waiting he must have been like
waiting for me right whatever
goes on life goes on what is psycho
lunatic boyfriend
three years later
Ted Bundy on the news face she was on a
date with Ted Bundy before he had
committed any murders or he had
committed murders but had not been
famous for it yet had not been convicted
of it yet she said when he saw him he
she literally almost fell out of her
chair because she was like that look she
said that Ted Bundy about you know how
you know everyone says he's so handsome
whatever she said he would get a look
over him when he was preying on a victim
which she was felt she was being preyed
on that she doesn't even look he's like
he does not look like that his face
configures and contorts to something
that looks so Sinister and that she
literally was like get me away from him
now so I was like whoa [__] Teddy B
imagine you on a date with Ted with a
young Teddy being
that'd be [__] nuts dude so he had
already committed murders and so he was
already and so he was looking to murder
her and he was giving that energy out
she said you know based off when all his
crimes were exposed from what the FBI
said when she went on a date with him
let's say it was 1978 he had already
been convicted uh connected to murders
in other parts of that because his first
murders were in like the Utah region and
that's where they were wild right holy
[__] dude [__] it's pretty it's
pretty nuts and then I think I might
have said this on the last one but TT
Jerry when she was in prison served
prison time with the Son of Sam she
shared a wall with the Son of Sam two
murderers she shared one with the Son of
Sam and um uh Ronald defeo from The
Amityville Horror house the man who
killed all those people in the you know
the movie The Amityville who was really
based off Ronald defale she was in
prison with both of them at the same
time and the prisoners from Escape from
dannemora who like that um Showtime show
that they made so she was in like real
deal prisoners but she said the Son of
Sam now this was months before the
Netflix documentary came out TT Jerry
said she's like you know the Son of Sam
David did not did not kill all those
people he was involved in a cult there
were other murderers but they the city
pinned it all on him and then a few
months later this Netflix documentary
comes out came out a couple years ago
basically saying that most likely Son of
Sam did not kill all those people he
killed maybe one or two but there was
other murderers that just got away with
it do you know the Henry Lee Lucas story
Henry Lee Lucas well utterly Lucas they
made a film about him called Henry
portrait of a serial killer okay and
it's a guy who got arrested for 62
murders and he was basically a Drifter
and he was traveling across the country
murdering people okay but
they think that what really happened was
they came up to him and they said you
know hey Henry you know there was a few
people that were killed behind the
bushes in Indianapolis in 76 we'd sure
love to solve that crime was that used
yep that's me I killed them too well how
did you do it with a knife because we
found a knife yep knife killed him with
a knife yeah and this guy was basically
a Dullard and may may have killed people
like made you know a lot of drifters
have killed people but it seems like
Google that make sure I'm correct on
this I think now they think that they
attributed a bunch of crimes to him that
he couldn't possibly have committed it's
a wild thing the depraved serial killer
who confessed to hundreds of murders see
this is it so it was more than 62 which
is what he was I think he was originally
charged with 600 people okay Drawn
Together by shared childhood trauma
Henry Lee Lucas and Otis tool became
lovers then serial killers who
terrorized America in the 1970s so it's
but but he confessed to hundreds of
murders but they think that some of them
he couldn't possibly have done but did
he stay in prison for the rest of his
life because of it
uh yeah he I think they might have
killed him in prison I don't know what
happened I don't know if he I don't know
if he's still alive but see see if he
got um if that's a story that they got
him to confess to a bunch of murders
that he couldn't have actually done
that's a common thing though right
people confess to stuff all the time you
know I I there's a show on Apple TV was
called Blackbird it just came out last
year it's about a real story about a guy
who what his tactic would be is is he
murdered a lot of people but he would he
would say to the police oh I murdered
that girl in that county I'm confessing
to it but then they would go through the
research and be like no you couldn't
have possibly but he would cop to it and
then the cops would be like he did that
like five times they'd like every County
he was investigating like that's what he
does he confesses to murders he's a
bullshitter but he really was killing
people he was using he was confessing to
false ones so he could get away with the
real ones holy wild right oh yeah [__]
so it's like some of these guys are so
smart
I think is William Hauser uh something
this is one of the best actors in my
generation no Joe I don't know if you
know this guy this guy's acting is like
um Daniel Day Lewis level he is a
phenomenal actor when you watch a show
Blackbird you cannot believe it where
I'm like and this is on Apple Plus Apple
TV it this is one of the best shows I've
seen came out last summer this oh [__]
this kid is literally like phenomenal
and then and then I'm watching 101
Dalmatians a day later with my kids and
he's in that I'm like look at his
[__] lunatic he plays uh Richard
Jewel yes uh Georgia Jewel movie about
the Olympic Park bombing yep wow
unbelievable actor he was also in that
in that sketch show I think you should
leave on Netflix which is one of the
funniest sketchos I've ever seen in my
life he's got great sketches in that
that guy but that show Blackbird was uh
it's unbelievable so basically what
happens is this guy who uh who's from um
he's from a bunch of movies this kid is
ripped by the way this kid has to be
intermittent fasting yeah
he's in the watch not the Watchman
though
um with uh with um yeah Samuel Jackson's
in it it's um it's a famous movie and
he's excellent but basically the premise
of it's based on a true story this guy
the guy the hottie with the body he gets
convicted 10 years in prison for gun
charges I think he's got out of
Massachusetts so and he was a good con
man right this is all real good con man
could you know gift to gab whatever so
the FBI wants to pin the the guy with
the mutton chops how's Earth they want
to pin Larry Hall is his name in real
life they want to pin murders on him
they know that they've kind of caught up
to his game now they know that he lies
about murders here to commit murder [__]
they know it but they got to convict
they got to get him to confess to one of
these murders because they found the
girl's body because he was killing kids
like 14 year old girls like brutal [__]
raping them horrific so they say to this
kid to the to the jacked guy they say
look you got The Gift of Gab you got 10
years in federal prison okay you're
three months into your sentence we're
gonna transfer you to this Maximum
Security Prison where Larry Hall is if
you can get him to confess to the murder
of this girl that we have evidence on
and you can get that your sentence is
commuted immediately and you're out of
prison that's all you got to do but he
was in a minimum security prison so he
would be able to either Coast through 10
years or take a chance and go to the
prison with murderers rapists and
potentially be murdered in the shower
stall
but if he can convince get this guy
gifted gab and get him to confess then
he'll get out holy [__] and that's what
the show's about and it was dude amazing
show like edge of my seat it was one of
the best shows I've seen in a long time
that's all I want to watch it I want to
watch it again on smelling salts thank
you for bringing that up I'm [__]
pumped about that I've been looking for
a new show yeah oh and by the way before
let me just finish a thought about Jerry
what I want to say is the Son of Sam
thing he said you know he was a serial
killer yes and don't get me wrong
murderer you know deserves to be in
prison he said the biggest [__]
lunatic like he was like the only person
who I met I was like this guy needs to
be like either put to death or kept like
in a cage like under the jail he said
was Ronald defeo who the Amityville
Horror house guy because he said he
would cook for him all the time around
the phone he would like let Ronald defeo
like jerk off to me they would put like
a prison mirror and he would like
because he was trans chairs he would
shake his ass a little bit and let
Ronald like get his rocks off whatever
he didn't care he said but every morning
he would make Ronald defeo Junior like a
little breakfast on his little
you know they had like little um hot hot
stoves in there they would let prisoners
like Jerry after you did enough time
give you some stuff you'd make a little
bacon and stuff for him and he said
every morning like clockwork seven days
a week every morning bring Ronald his
food and say how was your how was your
night Ronald how are you feeling he was
like good I feel good I just I didn't
kill my grandma it's the only thing I
just I I killed everyone in that house
but I did not get my grandma so but
everything other than that it's good and
cherry black okay and then keep so he's
like still he's in prison for the and
that is true the only one he didn't kill
in that house the grandma either got out
or wasn't there but he was he was like
there's no Rehabilitation for that man
he genuinely believes if he does not
kill his he would say to him if I don't
kill my grandma I'm not getting into
heaven so he had it warped he killed his
entire family and he's like that's how I
get to heaven but I gotta get the
grandma and then he died in prison
recently but I was like whoa whoa whoa
[__] I know it's it's wild